this morning president biden is on his
way home from his first trip to asia as
president the growing threat from china
was the main topic of discussion with
other asian pacific leaders a day
earlier mr biden caused the stir when he
said the u.s would defend taiwan
elizabeth palmer has been following the
diplomacy and u.s troops in the region
who are training to fight chinese forces
if needed
the group is known as the quad and the
president posed with the other leaders
japan's fumio kishida india's narendra
modi and a freshly elected anthony
albanese from australia the united
states must and will be strong steady
and enduring partner in the indo-pacific
that engagement is anchored by america's
huge military presence in the region
there are around 55 000 u.s troops in
japan alone
we joined the third battalion second
marines on the island of okinawa in the
rain for a training exercise
lieutenant robert booker's platoon is
defending this patch of jungle against
attackers sneaking up on them the enemy
in this exercise is another u.s platoon
but there isn't a marine involved today
that doesn't know this is a rehearsal
for a possible
chinese invasion of taiwan when you're
uh
doing these kinds of exercises these
days is taiwan on your mind
a hundred percent it is it yes ma'am
especially looking at the terrain things
like that
this is what we would encounter there
the island of taiwan considers itself
independent china maintains it's not
yesterday president biden reiterated
that the u.s would intervene if china
moved to seize it by force yes
that's the commitment we made
the administration quickly moved to
soften that stance our policy has not
changed china regularly sends its planes
and warships on aggressive sorties
around taiwan
and calls america's military presence in
the region a provocation
right now it's a war of words and here's
where the quad comes in
the militaries of japan india and
australia have done joint military
exercises with u.s forces recently
and that sends a big powerful message
that if push ever should come to shove
in this region when it comes to security
america is not alone tony
i hope it never gets to that point liz
palmer for us in tokyo elise thank you
very much